I know TT and Tita or auntie and um well  auntie TT is auntie that's all I know  Thai Langham an echo say yo I say lang  naman echo so yo a tiling naman yo yeah  but if they put on China but I feel like  that sounds dirty son China somebody  sending somebody to eat [ __ ] put on D my  peanut bejita fun Markel peanut Wow FINA  by Ricky that's long way being a pirate  mo Apple Tina Harrod Han Morocco  kailangan kappa guten yang kailangan  haben sie athenian got innocence in  detail  mama messiah in new - yeah in a tio  exclamation point my guy you know it's  beating you're worthless you're worth  nothing to me  para Tae Yong park a young Marine Park a  young Gabbar hang not even a Wallace uh  [ __ ] big new song pooja I know that last  one buckets in a sabi mo lang  yeah Cassie Lessing Naraku that's like a  lasting brother in what does it mean  let's get it on that's gonna say let's  go for doing this go for doing tonight  sounds like a Drake song oh good race